i don't want everyone to be
blackpilled here oh okay i want you to
see this story from bloomberg oh good
yes yes thousands protest in prague over
energy crisis
demonstrators gathered a protest against
the government in prague i think in
italy they were burning their energy
bills is that italy my uk doing the same
thing okay take a look at this
protests against the indonesian
government's 30 percent gas price hiker
in full force watch as protesters try to
break down a wall of police officers in
riot gear this is a political yeah
that's right it's bipartisan so what i
mean to say is
you know
people won't stand for this
and i don't believe
barack obama or bill gates or any of
these people they are not trustworthy
people they come to me as a young man
and say
good sir urban liberal we have a climate
crisis at hand and i say really tell me
more and they say that's right there's
too many people makes sense doesn't it
deer get overpopulated bird turkeys pigs
they can overpopulate right and i'm like
yeah and they go well we got a problem
we can't just kill people so we have to
work together to reduce our energy use
reuse and recycle and i'm like yeah that
all makes a lot of sense and they're
like now you get to it my private plane
is waiting to my beachfront property and
i'm like oh hold on there a minute
hold on i sacrificed and then you bought
beachfront property in martha's vineyard
these people are full of it if they
really cared about this stuff they
wouldn't be doing the things they're
doing no but i think the reality is is
that
they want to preserve what they have
they probably are worried about
overpopulation and political instability
but the reality is if we can get you to
sacrifice we get to keep our private
jets yeah so when they try to implement
these these control mechanisms it's like
you mentioned ian they want to control
the energy you get access to because by
limiting it it makes it easier to
control you if only the wealthy elites
have access to the internet or access to
these you know you know flying cars or
whatever they're an advantage over poor
people and they can more easily control
them
so now what we see is people are
protesting and rising up saying we do
not agree with this and that's what we
need to see because if people just lay
down and accept this then you're all
going to be pod people basically sheep
or chickens internet's kind of helped us
to smash class systems like there used
to be the elites and the plebes or the
plebs at least
and all through society there's been
better men and everybody else you know
whatever in the americas there were the
better men that made the government but
i think people are are not everybody but
more willing to represent themselves
what tim is saying is reminding me of
the criticism of the north america free
trade agreement it was like here's what
we're going to do as a collective you a
us canada mexico and part of the
environmental policies we're like we're
going to reduce carbon and do whatever
and mexico never reduced their uh carbon
emissions and so it was like wait we
were we said we were all in this
together and it was like but why are we
why are we staying in this agreement in
this partnership that's not working i
feel like that's the same thing that
these people are saying like we rely on
you to protect us and you are swearing
allegiance to a system that is causing
us to suffer like you are supposed to
put our interests first right they're
realizing their public servants are not
serving them anymore and that there is a
clear i think the class divide is
getting just so abundantly clear
especially through the internet and
independent journalism like if we
weren't talking about this and these
independent journalists weren't talking
about this nobody would know that all
these separate protests are happening
right now but now we're getting videos
coming out and different people are
jumping on the movements in the
netherlands when that started sooner or
later france jumps in spain jumps in
because they all know this is going to
be a collective fight i mean it was the
same thing with the freedom convoy right
we saw it happening in canada and people
were like oh wait yeah i don't want this
either we're gonna we're gonna act and
you didn't see it modeled as heavily
anywhere outside canada i mean people
carried out to a certain extent but like
that reminded everyone that like you
don't have to lay down and conform to
what's going on especially if it's
harming you i think it's funny i
remember the arab spring
you had uh
people using facebook and twitter to
organize mass protests in these arabic
nations and then you know overthrow
their governments egypt twice
and then we start seeing that with
occupy wall street people start
organizing and protesting occupy i think
got co-opted by you know
special interests but the ability to use
social media to organize and reject
these centralized control systems is
extremely apparent
and now they're desperately trying to
put a stop to it they have to ban people
like alex jones they have to silence as
many as many of these voices as possible
and they they first started going
through going for big names alex jones
for instance milonopolis laura loomer
none they started going after the
smaller accounts because they were like
hey maybe we can do it that way go after
a million small accounts that aren't big
enough to make a splash if they get
banned as opposed to the big one that
makes a big news cycle if you do ban
mm-hmm so that's the strategy now yeah
the other thing obviously is shadow
banning and you know algorithmic
manipulation the second benefit that i
heard to them is you know you ban these
people and if you're saying like oh
these they hold extreme views and they
get purged they look for an alternative
right so turbo talked about like gab was
not a inherently political uh
alternative to twitter except that they
banned all of the extreme right-wing
users first so they were like well we'll
go to gab and so that gave the platform
a natural leaning even though that
wasn't how he started it then you can
have anyone at twitter be like well what
are you gonna do join that crazy
extremist platform it siphoned off
society and made it so you can point
directly where you should not go next
the internet is very powerful i mean
like look at china and what's happening
there right now there's protests
erupting all over china because people
can't get their money out of the banks
but there's no they have such a
stronghold on social media and the
information that you're allowed to get
out of to people that it's so hard to
state approaching yes it makes me always
be like who is getting banned first
because whatever they're doing maybe i
don't agree with it but i want to know
because if they're getting purged first
just just be aware of it like why are
they getting purged
well
they do a lot of things somebody
commented already that um you know we've
got 40 000 people listening to the show
right now concurrent viewership we're
not trending on youtube
when you search for it you can't find it
and
it's election season so we knew this was
going to happen yeah but uh unsurprising
has that always been that way with the
show like did you ever trend on youtube
i can't remember i i think yes
early on we we did trend several times
i'm pretty sure
and then all of a sudden one day
uh i remember tim guest's irl you
couldn't search for it on google anymore
you would take the title verbatim put it
in google and facebook would come up
instead
and it was just funny and then it was
after like a year or so all of a sudden
i mentioned it on the show the next day
we reappeared in search but they i think
it was more that they realized it was so
overt people were catching on to their
suppression
right now i think it's funny because um
we put out a song last week everybody
knows at this point i guess and it was
trending number 23 on youtube which is
funny because this show gets more views
and it never trends
but this is the point of the culture war
putting out music is a political boy are
they really salty that we did that and
succeeded at it they're freaking out
some are but it was a good song so they
get that well it's like overwhelming
thumbs up and positive but the the
corporate press is losing their minds
when it comes to admitting social
networks politics is kind of a risky
admin because
if you decide to let politics run on the
front page of your social network you're
basically taking a political stance as a
as a social network administrator
whether you want to or not so you i used
to put that stuff in its own bucket like
if you want politics you got to go look
for it i'm not going to push it at you
i'm pushing you know letting
entertainment or what and it's like
that's a dirty surface level way to go
but politics is really dirty too and i
don't i don't think that just because
someone's got the loudest voice
necessarily means that everyone should
be looking at it people want power well
here's a question are left-leaning
people ever trending on youtube do you
guys keep up with that stuff yeah you
see yes well
i don't i don't know about prominent uh
overtly political yeah i don't know
about that if you look at it it's
usually music and like mr beast no so
every single time i turn on my smart tv
it's on youtube and it's on the young
turks every time it doesn't matter what
i do the young turks are an approved
youtube tv station right like they're
they're you get youtube tv and they're a
channel why are we a channel yeah what
the heck
they they have 24-hour coverage i'm
pretty sure like they have something
running on runs like a live stream for a
channel
so we can have a whole show where i just
vamp for an hour
i mean we're getting we're getting there
we have we have pop culture crisis three
to five we have tim cast irl eight to
ten we gotta start filling these these
time slots with other shows we're gonna
be launching the conspiracy show with
shane cashman which is like a call-in
show it's not gonna be live though but
we could air it in a time slot and then
maybe eventually get a 24-hour rolling
livestream does young turks do a website
where you pay 10 bucks a month and get
their stuff yup oh okay so they're doing
it for a long time i think we have more
i think we're bigger than they are to be
honest i'm not sure i see a lot of
left-leaning not always like a
politician or a commenter but i do see a
lot of presentation of you know it seems
like fun internet content right yeah
like rank all these people photos like
best fashion but it's always you know
you have to look at the people they have
certain ideologies they'll talk about
how they don't like certain things and
it's never from the conservative's
perspective it's always and i think
that's partially because youtube has
flagged let's say left-leaning culture
as mainstream culture yeah it's moving
us towards a left-leaning spectrum when
we know that's not actually accurate for
most of america exactly that is why i
started making videos i was just sort of
a passive user of social media but then
i started realizing how they curate the
content based on your demographics and
what they know about you and i started
getting all this stuff about black lives
matter and the black struggle and the
feminist struggle and i thought is there
nobody to counteract this on social
media and of course they are but they're
just getting throttled left and right
yeah yeah it's unbelievable
yeah
oh man i'm i'm gonna save something for
uh the next 17 20 minutes to give a
quick update on the on the culture war
issues so i'll save it but uh
yeah the the issue with
the uh with facebook and twitter is
algorithmic and early on what happened
was
people who ran these big tech companies
were naturally left-leaning they think
they're the majority so they would ban
what they thought was not normal
it's literally exemplified in that meme
where it's like the left and the right
and bernie sanders is placed in the
middle and there's nothing on the left
and it's like watch this space
and they're like it's like it's like
dude bernie sanders literally wants uh
the people to own percentages of
corporations that's socialist like
overtly if you think he's a centrist
you're in a cult but they do
they think i'm i'm a middle-of-the-road
person and and bernie sanders is in the
middle of the road no no he's not yeah
by no metric not by left and right uh
progressive like cultural standards and
not by economic standards he's left he's
fairly far left actually but they think
they're in the middle so they ban you
well it's the tech you're totally right
it's tech executives as well as
the area that they're in right so if we
think of hollywood and silicon valley as
similar areas both those industries are
dominated people who think who are
already naturally left-leaning and then
they walk outside and their kids have
friends at school who aren't in the
industry and they're also left leaning
and then it gets reinforced over and
over again it's why i'm so interested in
businesses like daily wire setting up in
in tennessee like businesses that want
to produce content especially now that
the internet gives us that flexibility
who settle in places that are not these
centralized you know echo chambers there
are physical echo chambers where people
all sort of think the same thing thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there